welcome to this video playing rethink
rethink from Sweden and let's play the
tango and played the solo the black
lights tango this is one of the better
somewhat offbeat openings around very
often transposing to two other openings
but it yeah that's this is an
interesting line I think capturing is
best it's it's a pawn sacrifice check
after this 97 II cannot defend e5
anymore but it's not it's not winning
hook like anything white can get some
compensation only problem is I have
forgotten how I really I forgot now I
think it starts with E force though you
for Knight takes Queen d4 or something
something like that is probably right
very often people stumble into this
though and they don't they don't know
anything wrong basically and just make
things as make up things as they go
along
yeah okay Knight f5 96 mm maybe maybe
Knight f5 Queen e5 queen is 7 this
should be quite ok actually yeah but the
night on let's go here come on the night
look at the unstable on there 5 really I
don't think I have a substantial problem
if I get in D 6 and D 6 H 6 like d 6e m
1 now the check can you even play king D
2 m and the queen and king I really as
strangely plays check Oh consider this
moment I don't want to return the pawn
so go here
maybe you can take queen takes rook e1
threatening checkmate
well 97 maybe yeah this is a tricky
yeah I feel I should be okay but it is
not not easy okay
look you wanna also have Bishop to f5m
this this is a good good defensive move
yeah Queen III I go King G ed King G H
to H son maybe you can take and play 94
okay but I'm not made then on on the 8th
so I can maybe drop all the way back to
see a true pho King g7 and then it's
just a trade interesting
let's win this temple hmm I wonder and I
have overlooked something more
interesting
takes Knight takes rook e8 can do that
it's not a terribly bad position
not even this is totally totally bad I
think let's do this
and just for coolness purposes just
looks totally crazy but I think it
should be okay
if he goes to a four I play b5 and
Bishop d7 if he goes to d3 I just play
Bishop d7 okay should I fire him yeah
okay but what what what can you do
need to play need to play something take
it rook e8
does not look very comfortable
admittedly but I also don't really see
how he's going to to to call me
nice u54 now a this was my idea too that
I get the square now but it just not
really help that much I really it really
doesn't
yeah least my my rock wall will play
okay I've gotten my rook into play not
sure if this is doing much good but it's
not a totally dead piece any more time
warning rook c8 nc6 or something draw
our third Jim
maybe I should tickets maybe I should
take it I can take these six you can
just take D 6cm Wow Wow now that was
there I need to take the draw and simply
miss miss Justice I thought I could I
could redo something but it's just not a
good position I can take him and now
I've got a pawn I can take night before
okay it doesn't I just there's no time
it really didn't look much at this time
okay yeah this this was very tricky I
mean White has a tremendous compensation
here I'm looking fine all I must play
this one of course this is much better
much better
rook III is a bad bad bad bad move after
that I mean I don't know I don't know he
has very very good compensation probably
he's better not sure how much but this
is excellent play for the pawn and what
I did
sorry rook e5 in comparison is just so
much stronger it attacks the night and
if he retreats I can just scrap here and
this is immensely helpful not because
it's the second pawn but also because
it's very important yeah taking piece in
a way that to limits my position with c6
covered and so on yeah after this black
is black is basically winning he needs
to give up the pawn all it needs to take
yeah and this take taking I mean I've
played 97 next and expel the f5 Knight
blacks just winning him yeah Wow yeah
yeah I felt like I made some progress
here but it's still it's still a
terrible position interesting the
computer wants to play b5 intending this
okay this might be a defense that's
better than the game that's better than
the game yeah I took took it took ages
to get the King into play but just a bad
position I should take the draw when he
offered the draw I'm not quite sure when
he did this around here I think I forgot
I forgot that that d6 thing hangs I
thought if he takes rook takes I can do
something against the pawn see'em that's
crazy really even that is good for white
but this is simply simply winning I
guess
yeah no that's not winning but that is
alright thanks for watching